>> So, ours will be more of
a collaborative presentation,
and so I call the rest
of the team in group
four to come here. All right.
>> Okay. So, this was the group
where we talked about
social awareness.
There are two NGOs that
were part of our group,
Salaam Bombay for tobacco
prevention generally
just as a reminder and
Anthyesthi for organ donation.
So, let me start with Anthyesthi.
So, I'm going to lay out
the set of AI challenges
and they'll speak to
the data they have
and what can be done.
So, if you recall,
their problem was
getting people to
become pledgees for
organ donation.
So, if we could predict
who will become a pledgee,
then we can focus
our marketing attention
on those people.
So, that's part of the question.
Second, which pledgee may
become a donor because
as you may recall,
there are six steps required
from pledgee to becoming a donor.
So, that will also help in
focusing our attention.
Which pledgee may become
an important
influencer in getting
other people to
become organ donors.
Chatbot to persuade people
to become pledgees.
So, this is much more futuristic.
So, these three are things
that are much more near term and
realistic and some of this
data is already available.
What I'm told that I've
been given some samples
more on that.
We have data from
the positive side,
the negative side data we
will gather in the future,
but I'm going to turn
this over to them,
to Anthyesthi to discuss
what data they have.
>> Thank you.
>> I'l go that way.
>> So, coming to the first point,
usage of machine learning to
increase the pledgee numbers.
So, right now,
the dataset that we have
is having certain set
of attributes.
That is let's say that people
whoever have donated blood in
the past or call it
social activists or existing
transplant coordinators.
We can also use Facebook pixel to
remarket people who
are website visitors.
So, these are the initial set
of people who already
shown some kind of inclination
towards organ donations.
Having this set of data,
what we plan to do in
the future plans as to how we
can implement machine
learning is that we
are going to come up with
the specific social media
audience marketing.
Is enabling the crowd
really aware of that?
How we can use
Twitter or in Insta,
LinkedIn, Facebook,
exactly audience marketing.
So, based on that,
we are going to get a certain
more in-depth attributes
about these kinds of people.
Let's say their
religious beliefs,
their political beliefs,
or how many of them
really have got interest
in charitable trusts.
This is how we slowly plan
to built the initial set of data,
who are probably for sure,
most probably to become pledgees.
Then taking
these characteristics,
we are going to do market to
all the possible audience who
are sharing certain attributes.
This is what we are
planning to do.
Yesterday, in the dinner
Mr. Amit Sharma
has shared to me about
his Learn to Earn program,
wherein they're
enrolling people by
teaching them about
the specific program
and then paying them for it.
So, it's like there is
a certain tutorial and
then they listen to tutorials
about once having
understood about that,
they get certain
mobile top up money.
This is a way how we can enroll
the rural people also to
know about organ donation.
So, these are the certain kind
of parameters that we
can get about data,
which currently all the social
media tools are providing.
All the [inaudible] or Facebook,
or Twitter or LinkedIn.
So, if I get to know a couple of
these parameters like
my data behavior,
my data's interests,
the demographics.
So, all this data,
having got this data about
the existing people,
then that's how I'm
going to get in
more and more people
into the complete gamut.
At the end, my vision is to
see everybody in India
know about what is
organ donations.
Because if you see
the crucial 24 hours,
based on our field visits,
what we've realized is
that it's about 24 hours
a grief counselor spends
in order to get
a relative consent.
But what if people
are already aware?
People need not be counselled for
telling the person on
death bed for
the organs we donated.
So, this is what can be
done in order to reduce
that 24 hours in the complete
six points that we
have mentioned.
Usage of machine learning to
improve influencer marketing.
So, here, the point
what I'm trying to
put forward is that
a pledgee may not really
become an actual donor,
but he can definitely
influence one.
If you see in reality,
let's if I pledged my organs,
the probability that I die
due to road traffic accident.
The probability that [inaudible]
brain dead and again,
the probability that I'm
going to donate my organs.
That probability is very bleak.
But yes, if I had been
an influencer in my lets
say community of one lack people,
if any person gets
to that stage then,
if I'm a decision-maker
in that relatives thing,
then definitely I'm game.
So our whole the thing
is that we should
be really using this for
the influencer marketing.
So, how one pledgee can
use his connection et
cetera to build a bigger group.
So, one way is that
family member connections,
LinkedIn connections,
customized lists re-marketing,
all these are specific tools of
the existing social
media platforms,
which we can use to increase
our pledgee database.
>> The road traffic accident part
and the date influence on
a local maybe police inspector,
who is first getting an emergency
call from a highway and
routing it to nearby
emergency department hospital
also take some time.
So, if something can be done
on this to fast capture
the data and the condition
of the patient
and actually get the facility
of good hospital,
can really make
a brain-dead person
more propensity to give an organ.
So, this is what we
are investing on in
the road traffic accident parts
and the society like
a police officer.
Like a person who is
the administrative head can be
connected to one single loop.
Maybe a social
connection that yes,
some road traffic accident
has happened,
and at the same time,
at the same moment
they're aware of.
>> So, we should
continue to move on
if you don't mind just so
that we can keep on time.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, then this is
a futuristic advanced AI
wherein we are continuously using
machine learning to predict
the success rate of
organ pairing and organ
matching improving
the quality of lives.
So, currently this
is the data that we
have from other
foundations that is,
this is from Tamil Nadu.
We can year on year we know that
how many organs
have been donated.
But what if you also have
the data that in we
are knowing that okay,
kidney A is getting
bad with kidney B and these
are the specific parameters.
So, if the 10 cases using
specific attributes,
if there were three failures,
the more the machine learns
that failure rate
can be decreased.
Because we are actually
doing lot of matching
with the parameters.
So finally, how
can we use machine
learning to predict
the conversion of
pledging to real organ donor.
Step one would be
is that we first
start targeting
the high-yield areas.
How do we get a high-yield area
in India if we know
that this is the place where
a lot of road traffic
accidents happen?
Then we start implementing
our complete model of
making every digitally
aware person
in that city to a pledgee.
Then, we use technology to
totally reduce the time delay of
right from getting
brainstem donor
to converting a transplant.
So it's all one big
collaborative effort.
Yeah. We just want to reduce
the delays in
each level involved.
Any questions?
>> Let's wait till their
presentations is also there.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> So, the next NGO
that was involved with
Salaam Bombay
tobacco-free schools,
and I wanted to summarize
the main points that
came up in our
conversation with them.
So, one is to predict
which school will
become tobacco-free,
based on some features because
this will help determine
which schools may need
extra training to make
them tobacco free.
They also do
random checks of some of
the schools because
the submitted data may be false,
and so 10 percent of the
schools get monitored,
and so which 10 percent
should be randomly checked.
So, this is also
an interesting problem,
and automatically because
they get thousands of
schools sending in
data automatically
verifying whether the evidence
submitted is accurate or not.
Some of the pictures
may be duplicates
of other schools and so forth.
So, I'm going to turn
this over to them.
>> Yeah. So basically,
we are working towards
making schools tobacco-free.
With the limited time
and limited resources,
we are trying to-
basically there is a law,
which says all the
public premises and
including schools that has
to be like tobacco-free.
So, what we do, we do
basically there are 29 percent
of the adults in India.
They consume smokeless tobacco,
15 percent of the youth
consume tobacco in India,
5,500 people youth especially
they test tobacco products
first-time every day.
So, you can imagine how
vast the problem it is.
So, what we are doing
or how AI can help,
see we being an NGO,
we cannot change everything.
So, we are focusing on
the schools and children
because children are
the future of the society.
So, what we are saying
building, scalable,
and sustainable tobacco control
and prevention
strategy through AI.
So, we are working
with the schools,
we will collect the
data from the school.
So, if that premises of
the school is
tobacco-free or not.
For that we are capturing
the 11 criteria,
there are for example has
the medical checkup done or not.
Is there an awareness
session is done or not.
Is there any board
at the main gate.
Is there any notice board,
we now bear with
the principal's cabin et cetera.
These kind of
11 criteria are these,
these are the minimum criteria,
of course there has
to be like awareness
and capacity building
has to be done.
With these minimum 11 criteria,
we collect the data from
the all the schools,
and we work in we want to
do 100 percent schools
tobacco-free in
Maharashtra and then
gradually at the national level.
So, minimum, we require
lot of manpower.
We cannot afford that.
So with the AI, we're
looking to is it possible
to minimize the efforts to
check all each and
every parameters which
are filled by the schools
and there is a lot
of manual work.
To check all the 11 criteria.
So, for example, there are
1,09,000 schools in
only Maharashtra.
So, to check every
single criterion photo,
we need to check 11 lakh entries.
So, that's quite a
challenging task for us.
So, these are few proposed
solution we can work on.
So, we have categorized it.
It is few AI solution
and there are other
some technological
improvement solution also.
Based on the existing data,
we can make predictions.
Instead of paying attention,
all our districts
and all the schools
at one time we can just predict
what are the difficulties
from coming from which parts.
So, for example, if there is
a tribal belt and they don't have
basic resources to fulfill
those 11 criteria.
So, maybe we can predict
that prediction from the data.
So, our team with
a very limited resources,
we can focus on those areas.
Then can if it's time and
resources permits then we
can focus on those things.
The current training model
is a cascade model,
there is transmission loss.
So, we go to the districts,
we train the trainers,
who are the master trainers
are from all the local,
all the block level schools.
Then those master
trainers goes to
their respective blocks and
they conduct the training there.
So, it's very subjective
thing how efficient
and perfect to give
the information and
influence basically.
Yeah, and the another thing,
yeah it's very again subject
to which trainers to select,
and there are a lot of
queries also regarding
the technical thing also on
the tobacco information.
So, we can introduce the chatbot,
there are a lot of calls
coming in our office.
So, we are not able to login.
We are not able to
do these things.
So, we introduce the chatbots,
where are all the principals
and all the trainers are there.
So, they can get
the solution right there.
This is basically, I
mean the simple model.
There is a problem with
the AI intervention.
We will be able to
train the trainers,
one-to-one right from
the centralized place,
creating IEC material,
making it available
right there at the app.
AI predictions can
be helped identify
which schools need
extra trainings or
maybe extra IEC material
and some extra focus.
10 percent monitoring
this is again
a crucial concern for us
with the minimum resources,
we cannot crosscheck all
the 1,09,000 schools.
If we get what kind
of rejections or
what challenges are coming
with particular
district or block,
then we can standardize
our monitoring system.
Then impact we will
be created tobacco free
schools obviously,
at least for the children
and at least for
the primary and
secondary schools,
we can provide healthy
environment for the children.
We have data available
with us with the schools.
We have all that means with
the UIDs and the
11 criteria right now,
and we can also,
we are planning to,
I mean data collect,
if specific data if
needed. Yeah, thank you.
>> Great.
>> What makes you- what evidence
you have [inaudible].
>> So, those organizations,
that'll be awesome.
>> So, your shopping
preferences might not be
a specific parameter for.
>> He said you're getting
group of preferences.
>> Yeah.
>> You are going to launch
it and social media as well.
So I decided how [inaudible].
>> That was like
just one parameter which
can be used amongst
multiple parameters
but that might not be used freely
for the organization. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, one
of the reasons I'm
suggesting that exactly
to be is there's
a general move to not just
use all the data that you
can collect from out people in
an unmotivated way as
a training model for AI.
It's a general idea that
this is a bad thing,
and once Facebook might do it,
there's also a general idea
that Facebook is
not particularly
ethical organization.
So, one thing to think about,
I think is to just be a little
bit ethical because you
have the very ethical laws
that you want to be something.
So, the thing that I
suggest is the thing,
what are the parameters you
really build that might have
some impact on whether someone in
this organization and
then work within those,
and don't just do
a really broad discussion,
which is basically
Vikram's questions and
make sense. Does that make sense?
>> Yes, yes. It does.
All right. Thanks.